I am Paul find some reason TV we're here
at liberto Pia in San Diego talking with
judge Jim Gray the vice presidential
candidate for the Libertarian Party
great to have you with us Jim how you
doing Paul it's always nice to be with
good people and I'm doing just great i'm
excited enervated a little frustrated
but we're moving forward well tell tell
our viewers why should people vote for
the ticket of Gary Johnson and Jim Gray
it makes so much difference you know
we've been running to win we are more
qualified really governor gary johnson
has more administrative experience than
both President Obama and Governor Romney
combined as we speak he has ideas you
can listen to these hundreds of millions
of dollars of ads being spent by by
Obama by Romney they don't talk about
their record because they don't have one
to run on they don't talk about their
ideas they don't have any what they do
is say that they so how inept the other
one is and honestly we agree with both
of them we do have ideas we are
qualified and we will actually work to
the people plus we have that trump card
that the American people crave namely we
will be able to put in a coalition
government yes of libertarians and
independence but as long as they agree
with our approach of financial
responsibility and social tolerance also
Republicans and Democrats and then when
we get this bipolar politics going on in
Washington today we'll have some of
their own colleagues in our
administration go out come on guys get
on board this is a good idea will
actually give credit to people that have
good ideas support good ideas instead of
this paralysis going on today and you've
been on the road a lot campaigning
what's that what's the thing that struck
you the most or the most interesting
thing you found you know talking to
people about your approach it's just
exciting you people have that oh yeah
experience they realize that no we don't
have to have our troops in military
fights all around the world they realize
that somebody is there to say
unless there's a security interest of
the United States a security threat
we're not going to attack Iran we're not
going to go to war with Iran we're going
to bring our troops home now from
Afghanistan we're not the world's
policemen the whole Patriot Act which
they're so frustrated about it's a
direct frontal assault on our civil
liberties does not make us safer will
repeal it the TSA I mean they go through
and do that a lot and people realize
that odd the grand illusion of security
it really could be better if it was
privatized yes we do need those
securities in here let the airline's do
it much more sensible much less
intrusive much more cost-effective so
people just get that that light goes on
and it's just a blessing and a privilege
to watch it happen what kind of message
you have for a person say a soccer mom
from my neck of the woods in Orange
County who's you know she's probably
thinking about voting for Obama because
he seems like he cares a little a little
bit more she's worried about the safety
of her kids and well-being of poor
people and we're until you know going
through a tough economic times what
would you say to that person people are
beginning to understand that unless you
really want money from the government
Obama is a really complete failure
fortunately he doesn't know how to
govern because if he did we'd been worse
shape today than we are but they realize
that this hope in this change is an
illusion they realized that he's lots of
talk he's a gifted speaker and we're in
worse shape today you know they're
realizing that the future of those very
children that they're talking about is
an jeopardy a lot of Republicans that
will say that if you you shouldn't vote
for Gary Johnson because you know you
should vote for Romney because what we
really need is to get obama out of
office what do you say you know to
people who don't necessarily ss-sir
necessarily big fans of mitt romney but
they think he's probably the bed the
better of the two bad options you know
something it's that wasted vote syndrome
and it's a big obstacle that we have in
our campaign the answer is look if
you're in California for example of my
home state Obama's going to win
California and vote for Romney and Obama
is a wasted vote get us our five percent
will be a part of the system in the
future and it will be the beginning of
the end of the two-party system that
vote counts in fact even my sister who
lives up in San Francisco area she's a
Democrat she's telling her Democrat
friends a vote for Obama is a wasted
vote because he's going to win anyway
vote for governor gary
Johnson then there are other approaches
to if you are a Democrat and Obama does
not represent you it's a wasted vote to
vote for Obama because you're telling
the Democratic Party this type of
candidate this types of action you know
the NDAA the Patriot Act all of these
these threats and use of our military
forces you're telling the democratic
party this is okay so they'll put up
other candidates like that if Romney and
you're a Republican does not represent
you it's a wasted vote to vote for
Romney for the same reason you're
telling the Republican Party that
Romneycare Obamacare is okay etc or the
continuing increase of the federal
government so finally of course you also
have it's more of a trite phrase you
vote for the lesser of two evils you
still get evil but the ultimate decision
is a wasted boat is voting for somebody
you don't believe in so vote for someone
we actually should put out bumper
sticker saying vote for instead of
against and then just put governor gary
johnson below it i think it would work
honestly I don't know what Obama
believes at this moment I don't know
what Romney believes at this moment
except they want to win the election I
dunno what governor gary johnson
believes go to gary johnson 2012 com you
too will know what governor gary johnson
thinks will agree on the big things
maybe not all of the smaller things but
at least you'll know where we stand and
he like I have a big defect in effect as
a candidate because will tell the truth
it's unusual today but I'm too old to
change I've been a judge for 25 years
and I'm not going to change now governor
gary johnson has shown that he'll do the
right thing for the right reason he's
the guy proud to be with him well good
look at November thanks for being with
us good luck to us all and thank you
thank you for reason TV I'm Paul fine